en neuf ans le dernier quelques jours
après son élection la mairesse de
montréal valérie plantes affirmé avoir
découvert un trou de 358 millions de
dollars dans le budget de la ville
le trou et là il faut le combler en fait
ce montant-là épais hypothétique
il venait des prévisions budgétaires
pour l'année 2018 donc pour les mois à
venir
ce que ça veut dire sexy la ville
réalise tout ce qu'il ya sur sa liste
d'épicerie pour 2010 8 déc les élus ne
prennent aucune décision pour ajuster
les dépenses ou les revenus à la fin de
l'année 2018
il va y avoir un manque à gagner de 358
millions de dollars 140 millions de
dollars de surplus
c'est complètement autre chose le 140
millions de surplus
c'est le résultat réel de l'année 2010
est une année durant laquelle denis
coderre a été maire de montréal dès ce
mois sur 12
[Musique]